when elon musk's first wife justine
replied to a question on quora about how
someone can be as great as elon or other
super successful people she wrote these
people tend to be freaks and misfits who
are forced to experience the world in an
unusually challenging way
elon musk grew up in pretoria south
africa and said he had an unhappy and
lonely childhood he didn't spend much
time playing with other kids because he
has aspergers he struggled to pick up
social cues and to understand that
sometimes people didn't say exactly what
they meant but instead spoke
figuratively he only started to figure
it out by immersing himself in books and
watching movies musk even mused that
perhaps he read too many comics as a kid
telling ashley vance in his 2015 book
about him in the comics it always seems
like they are trying to save the world
it seemed like one should try to make
the world a better place because the
inverse makes no sense
it's no coincidence musk has made it his
mission to make a mark on the world with
self-driving electric cars and plans to
colonize mars his brilliance was
apparent from an early age his father
errol once said that when elon was three
or four years old his son asked him
where is the whole world
in other words where did earth sit in
the grand scheme of the universe quite
the question for any young child to ask
things were not great at school in fact
they were painful he endured years of
ruthless bullying as detailed in ashley
vance's book one day in eighth or ninth
grade musk recalled how he and his
brother kimball were sitting on the top
of a flight of stairs eating when a boy
snuck up behind him kicked him in the
head and shoved him down the stairs
before a bunch of boys beat him until he
blacked out
the beating damaged his nose so badly it
restricted the airflow for which he
later had surgery the bullies even beat
up musk's best friend until he agreed to
stop hanging out with him musk recalled
in vance's book moreover they got him
they got my best bleeping friend to lure
me out of hiding so they could beat me
up and that hurt
vance described how while telling this
part of the story musk's eyes welled up
and his voice quivered for some reason
they decided that i was it and they were
going to go after me non-stop that's
what made growing up difficult
for a number of years there was no
respite you get chased around by gangs
at school who tried to beat the [ __ ] out
of me and then i'd come home and it
would just be awful there as well it was
just like non-stop horrible
elon's mother may in errol divorced when
he was eight
mae said she left an abusive
relationship she ran away with the three
children and it was a struggle raising
them as a single mom the model and
nutritionist saved up what she had and
when money got tight she fed the kids
peanut butter sandwiches and bean suit
elon eventually chose to live with his
father for a while as he felt bad that
his dad was living alone one has to
wonder if elon regretted that decision
as he told rolling stone he was such a
terrible human being you have no idea my
dad will have a carefully thought out
plan of evil he will plan evil i went
into detail in another video about
elon's relationship with his father
which i'll link in the description in
response to elon's portrayal of him
errol musk told rolling stone i've been
accused of being a gay a misogynist a
pedophile a traitor a rat a [ __ ] quite
often a bastard by many women whose
intentions i did not return and much
more my own wonderful mother told me i
am ruthless and should learn to be more
humane
but he concluded i love my children and
would readily do whatever for them
elon found comfort in coding by the time
he was 12 he coded a space-themed video
game called blastar a south african
magazine published the source code and
gave him 500
the game was by no means a marvel of
computer programming but it did hint at
the genius brewing inside of him he
would turn his science fiction fantasies
into reality when he founded spacex at
the age of 30 in 2002 his enthusiasm to
explore space also has roots in the
existential crisis he suffered as a
teenager he studied religious texts to
learn the meaning of life he ended up
embracing the lessons in the
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy by
douglas adams in which musk says the
lesson is figuring out what questions to
ask and then the answer will be
relatively simple
musk has said his aim is to increase the
scope and scale of human civilization so
that we'll learn more become more
enlightened and are better able to
understand what questions to ask the boy
who fantasized about space and found
solace in coding would later learn to
fight back against his bullies he went
through a growth spurt and by the time
he was 16 he was a towering six feet
tall he also trained in karate judo in
wrestling and as he told rolling stone i
started dishing it out as hard as they'd
give it to me when he knocked out the
biggest bully in school with one punch
he noticed that the bully never picked
on him again he told the magazine it
taught me a lesson if you're fighting a
bully you cannot appease a bully you
punch the bully in the nose and perhaps
that mentality shaped elon musk has yet
to fight to keep tesla and spacex alive
even when the odds were heavily against
him he also had to fight to prove his
father wrong when elon was 17 he moved
to canada his mother's birth country and
eventually ended up here in toronto he
said his dad didn't think he could make
it and told him he'd be back in south
africa within months and that he was an
idiot for trying he did two years of his
undergrad at queen's university in
kingston three hours drive east of
toronto but the goal was always to get
to america
after two years at queens he transferred
to the university of pennsylvania his
ticket to the promised land
as a young boy growing up in south
africa when apartheid was in its final
years but there was still tension and
violence he saw america as the land of
opportunity for him it was more than a
cliche it was the one place where a
lonely quiet kid with a talent for
computers could make something of
himself
no one could have predicted that he'd
become one of modern america's greatest
industrialists and perhaps arguably the
greatest entrepreneur of all time
elon musk is a supremely talented
engineer if you look to strive to become
like musk or simply want to improve your
computer science skills my sponsor
brilliant is an incredible way to learn
stem interactively their computer
science fundamentals course is perfect
for you if you like to learn the
fundamentals of computer science or
strengthen your knowledge of core
computer science concepts and no coding
is required if you'd like to dig deeper
and learn more about artificial
intelligence their introduction to
neural networks course is a great way to
learn about data processing machines by
experimenting hands-on my personal
favorite are the logic courses that
really improve your critical thinking
skills there are no tests on brilliant
and if you ever get stuck you can read
the explanation for more brilliant is
free to try if you head to the link in
my description or pin comment
brilliant.org newsthink and the first
200 people to click on my link will get
20 off the premium subscription which
gives you unlimited access to all of
their offerings thanks for watching for
news think i'm cindy palm